also das ist echt so episch es sind
einfach genau die gleichen Sounds wie in
der Serie in den Spielen das ist so
[Musik]
geil hey Leute und herzlich willkommen
zur mit unfangreichsten Mod die ich
bisher je gespielt habe bzw hier
vorgestellt ich habe ja letztens bzw
gestern ja schon in dem
Vampire Set geschnittenen Video von mir
gesagt dass heute eine Mod kommen wird
um 14:30 Uhr die mega heftig ist und es
ist die Dragon Ball C Mod bzw halt
Dragon Ball Z wird in Minecraft
hinzugefügt und es sind so viele neue
Sachen die hier dazugefügt werden ihr
seht schon das sind alles Kisten mit
Dingen die hinzugefügt werden da sind
auch noch so ein paar Sachen und zwar
werde ich euch ein paar Dinge zeigen was
heißt ein paar ich werde euch das meiste
zeigen aber ein paar Sachen lasse ich
euch auch noch so ein bisschen vor dass
ihr die selbst entdecken könnt wie z.B
andere Planeten wie z.B namc oder oder
andere Leute wie z.B Freezer oder so die
Freezer Sager oder Story oder halt sowas
alles dass ihr das halt selber entdecken
könnt ich werde euch jetzt das Video
werde ich auch in zwei Teile einteilen
und zwar dass ich euch jetzt erstmal so
ein paar Dinge zeige wie beispielsweise
die Rezepte und schon mal eine grobe
Sache was die Sachen zer können danach
werde ich ein Cut machen und danach
werde ich in eine andere Welt gehen wo
ich die Story schon ein bisschen
angespielt habe ja es gibt auch eine
Story also ihr euch wird hier echt eine
Menge erwarten und da werde ich dann
zeigen wie die Sachen in der Anwendung
aussehen wie ein paar Mops aussehen wie
es gter funktionieren wie man seine
Dragon Ball C ERF Dragon Block C
Erfahrung irgendwie verteilen kann etc
etc etc und ich würde sagen wir fangen
eigentlich direkt mal an ich habe immer
so ein paar Kisten und zwar ich ma das
mal ganz kurz aus ich Cheat natürlich
nicht h quatsch ich hab das natürlich
alles selbst geholt wenn man acht Weizen
nimmt und ein Ei kriegt man eine
sensubohne die füllt die komplette
hungerleiste
auf und die ist halt nicht unendlich das
ist halt was ganz normales die könnt
euch so craften dann könnt die Frasen
und bter in der Story kriegt die später
auch von Namik ich weiß gerade nicht
mehr genau wie der heißt Kami Nami Naki
ich weiß nicht der wohnt oben auf so
himmelsschloss Dings buum unter diesem
bunten Teil aber zeige ich euch gleich
auch noch da gibt die immer morgens da
könnt ihr euch auch welche abholen dann
haben wir hier wenn man acht Eisen so
anorden wie so ein Schild kriegt man ein
Katana Blade das hat schon plus 5
Angriffsschaden mal als Vergleich das
höchste Schwert hier hat plus 24 ein
diamantschwert hier hat plus 7
Eisenschwert was normales hat + 6 und
hier kriegt man schon aus acht Eisen so
ein plus 5 Katana Blade also die
Aufteilung sind noch ein bisschen
schwammig
wenn man ein Leder nimmt ein Eisen und
ein Leder dann bekommt man ein Katana
hilt das hat auch schon plus Angriff
plus 5 Angriffsschaden und wenn man die
beiden Sachen dann verbindet hat man ein
Katana also das ganz normale Katana
nicht Schwert sondern das ganz normale
Katana ist halt auch ein Schwert hat
plus 14 angriffschaden also schon
doppelt so viel wie ein diamantschwert
dann wenn man zwei Katana Blades hat und
ein kating Shad wie man den kriegt den
kriegt man halt von Drachen etc zeige
ich euch gleich auch noch oh mein Gott
das wird so lange dauern und ich bin
auch nicht der größte Dragon Ball expert
ich habe nur ein paar Folgen immer so
paar Folgen so 20 30 Stück aber ich bin
halt mehr so Pokémon Freak abhängig
deswegen verzeiht mir so ein paar Sachen
wenn ich ein paar Sachen falsch
ausspreche dann bekommt man jeden Fall
das brave Sword Battle da denkt ihr euch
jetzt erstmal das gleiche wie ein Katana
Blade ja aber wenn man sich noch ein
brave Sword hilt macht und die beiden
verbindet hat man plus 19 angriffschaden
also Doppel Diamant plus noch mal F
drauf und ja dann haben wir hier ein Z
Sword Blade das ist genauso wie die
anderen das ist genauso also nicht
genauso crafting Bar da braucht halt
zwei katching Shots mehr und ihr werdet
auch nachher wissen dass so zwei sch mir
schon echt schwieriger zu bekommen sind
dann gibt's den se Sword hilt und dann
kann man sich ein SE Sword machen was
ich auch schon in der Hand habe oder z
Sword heißt es glaube ich plus 24
angriffschaden fast jeder Mob ein Schlag
ich glaube Creeper zwei Schläge oder
drei sogar aber nicht glaub Creeper zwei
Schläge aber alle anderen Mobs halt nah
zu zwei Schläge das ist echt so heftig
also Schweine und so dann wird auch ein
neuer oh hinzugefügt bzw ein neues erst
und zwar wie wir es alle kennen Warren
crystals daraus kann man sich die
Rüstung machen zwar Battle Armor Tor so
Battle om with Armor und Battle Armor
Boots Kopf gibt es davon noch nicht also
das hier sieht aus wie so ein Kopf aber
das ist das halt fürs für Dash hier für
das hier an Kopf muss nämlich die
Scouter der einem zeigt wie stark Gegner
sind wie weit Gegner weg sind etc ich
erkläre es jetzt mal ganz so ein
bisschen für so die Leute die vielleicht
jetzt so gar nicht so richtig wissen was
Dragon Ball so richtig ist Dragon Ball
ist eine Serie das solltet ihr wissen
dann dieses Ohr hier kann man mit ganz
normaler Spitzhacke abbauen ich kann
mich jetzt mal eben hier so
das könnt ihr auch hiermit abbauen das
dauert halt immens lange mit der
eisenspitzhacke dauert es auch noch sehr
lange allerdings könnt ihr es halt mit
allen möglichen Spitzhacken abbauen hier
ich baue das ab und da ist den Kristall
hier Dings Boms und ja den habt ihr dann
halt creative gehen wir mal wieder also
das ist ab mit jeder PI pickaxe aber es
dauert halt sehr lange dann hier auf
einem anderen Planeten hat man diesen
dirty Cobblestone und den dirty Stone
den man daraus macht wie man das kriegt
und abbaut wisst ihr glaube ich alle und
es gibt es halt nur auf anderen Planeten
außerdem gibt's nur auf anderen Planeten
z.B hier Sachen wie Basic wallstone oder
namc Grass das ist halt auf namc das
Gras und daraus werden da die Häuser
gebaut also ich will jetzt nicht auf die
ganzen Planeten hier reisen weil man da
erstmal weiter in der Story sein muss
und also in der Story die man spielt und
soweit bin ich noch nicht weil ich das
gerade selber nur so ein bisschen
durchspiele nein ich ma davon kein Let's
Play weil wartet mal heute abend ab
wartet mal heute abend 18 Uhr ab und
dann werdet ihr wissen warum freut Euch
auf 18 Uhr ja schön müs aber noch warten
na ja jedenfalls das gibt's auch auf
anderen Planeten und habe ich zwar
selbst noch nicht gefunden aber ist halt
helles Gras also hell heller Erde also
dann gibt's noch aisa saplings aisa wood
und aisa leaves oder aisa das gibt's
halt auch alles auf dem anderen Planeten
das sieht so aus das ist dieses Holz das
Holz ist auch sehr witzig das wird hier
angezeigt als jetzt nicht mehr vorhin
wird das als so dicker Holzblock
angezeigt aber es ist halt so ein dünner
Holzblock halt eine andere Art von
Bäumen so die Bäume sehen noch nicht so
aus die sehen anders aus aber ich habe
es jetzt halt mal so aufgezeichnet weil
ich kenin Bock hatte die nachzumachen so
kan wir weitermachen und zwar kann man
die auch in die battlearmor kann man
auch so ein bisschen f mit kakaobohn
dann sieht die so aus so aus oder so aus
man kann die auch anders färben indem
man noch ins dazu nimmt dann sieht die
so aus so aus oder so aus dann kann man
die auch noch mal so färben das ist noch
mal ein anderer Battle amator so der ist
ein bisschen weniger mäßig so aber das
macht kein großen Unterschied weil die
eh schon stärker ist als diamantrüstung
dann kommen wir zu den Sachen hier das
ist einfach blau gefärbt hier weiß
gefärbt auch hellblau gefärbt auch
hellblau gefärbt auch hellblau gefärbt
grün gefärbt rot gefärbt grün gefärbt
und jetzt kommen wir zu den scoutern und
zwar sind die scoutern deswegen
wichtig ich habe z.B ein roten hier an
mir dran ein lilanen und ihr seht jetzt
hier z.B links ach egal das zeige ich
euch gleich einfach die Scouter craftet
man auf jeden Fall indem ihr hier
irgendeinen Farb Blabla nimmt in welcher
Farbe ihr es halt haben wollt dann hat
man hier Glas dann da ein waren Crystal
und TEAG TEAG chiptier
ein wenn ihr gleich ihr bleibt ihr
bleibt einfach dran ihr guckt euch
einfach weiter an wenn ihr das wissen
wollt dann haben wir hier diese ganzen
anderen Sachen das ist Turtle School g
auch Turtle School g aber Hosen und da
gehe ich jetzt einfach mal so durch die
Sachen sind halt einfach wie
Lederrüstung und das ist halt soll so
ein bisschen die Kleidung von so ein
paar anderen Leuten in Dragon Ball
darstellen könnst mal schreiben wenn ihr
ein paar Sachen hier erkennt ich meine
sowas wie future Pants oder diese diese
future shoes und vor allem warte wo
waren sie vor allem das sollte man
erkennen von wem das ist schreibt das
mal in die Kommentare wenn du das schwi
dann haben wir hier ein spacepot
spacepot komme ich gleich auch noch zu
das sind so Sachen damit man halt so
rumfliegen kann Blabla auch acht Warren
crystals und ein Tech Chip Tier dann
haben wir hier den Dragon Radar Dragon
Block Radar only Dragon Block that not
stonifi can be detected hier findet man
jetzt glaube ich sogar sehr viele ja
hier findet man sehr viele weil das eine
Creative Welt ist die ich erstellt habe
und hier liegen halt echt eine Menge
Dragon Balls rum wo ist der wo ist der
W da ist der da ist jetzt z.B Dragon
Ball den kann ich jetzt z.B wenn ich
dann nicht im Creative im Creative hau
ich jetzt einfach kaputt und ist halt
vom Radar weg und hier sind halt echt
extrem viele also da schon der nächste
und eigentlich sind die so schwer zu
finden ne aber werdet ihr auch gleich
sehen im Survival habe ich nämlich noch
gar kein gefunden jedenfalls sollen die
auch schwer zu finden sein und mit
Dragon Block Radar kann man die Dragon
Balls bzw Dragon Blocks heißen se ja
kann man die ausfinde ich machen so
macht man sich die Tech Chip Tiers
einfach hier so ne so macht man die Tech
Chip ti 2 dafür braucht man teip ti 1
und teip Tier 3 macht man man teip Tier
2 davon braucht und ein teip Tier 1 und
dre Diamanten und D
la so das war erstmal die crafting
Rezepte jetzt kommen wir zum etwas
entspannteren Teil an alle die vom Intro
aus hier hin geskippt haben ich habe so
eine Anmerkung in der Beschreibung
gemacht wenn ich es nicht gemacht habe
habe ich es vergessen und dann hi ich
bin Luca ich bin dumm B vergesslich und
faul wie ein Faultier ja wusstet ihr
übrigens D faulti Faultiere wenn die auf
dem Boden liegen dann dann bleiben die
einfach liegen es gibt ein Video auf
Youtube faulti das liegt einfach auf dem
Boden und dann schmeißen das so Leute
durch die Luft und dann fliegt es und
dann ist so so ein videout so believe
fly aber das ist eine andere Story na ja
gut ich ma ganz kurz K dann sehen wir
uns anderen Welt wieder herzlich
willkommen in einer anderen Dimension na
ja so anders ist die Dimension gar nicht
und zwar muss ich euch ganz kurz was
erzählen wenn man also ich habe jetzt
nichts falsch gemacht das hört gerade so
an so ich muss e eben was beichten so ne
alles gut bei mir es regnet Jungs ich
kann kein Befehle eingeben der schwegen
ist den Sache hier wo ma ich das hier
bin SP da
hallopendt ich habe da drauf gedrückt ob
du dumm bist habe ich
gefragt okay hört auf du behindert bist
Spaß minecraft ist nicht
behindert cybermans man man Plural von
man ist man also man wir du man im
Plural bisschen Englisch hier auch noch
oh wir sind schon bei 10 Minuten Jungs
wir müssen Biss durchziehen soll auch
nicht eine halbe Stunde lang werden wird
aber wahrscheinlich ihr könnt im
Survival eine Welt starten und dann
spawt ihr eigentlich so mittlerweile zu
fast 9 100% 9 100 ach muss de Tim hier
so jetzt hab wir eine schöne Kulisse
dann spawt ihr weiß nicht irgendwie da
oder so halt direkt neben so ein Biom
das ist halt nicht weit weg das ist halt
das Biom wo wie gesagt legher Dirt ist
dirty Stone und halt auch Cobblestone
mis abbaut und so das ist halt diese
Dimension also ich sag das jetzt mal das
ist auch ein anderer Planet für mich
sind das nämlich andere Planeten hier ja
dann
fals haben wir halt hier erstmal diese
paar Häuschen bisschen klein ne also da
fliegen wir gleich auch noch hoch da ist
übrigens erstmal also
ich ich bin nicht sortiert und ich bin
so aufgeregt weil es so eine Mod gibt
und die gibt's halt schon länger es
gibt's die Mod schon länger aber ihr
wisst dass ich ich bin nicht so ein Typ
der die Mods so vorstellt so von wegen
ja jetzt haben wir hier das und das ich
gehe hier lieber so ein bisschen chillig
was durch dass ihr dabei irgendwie ein
Kaffee trinken könnt und euch nicht in 5
Minuten alles merken müsst also ich gehe
das chillig mit euch durch wenn ihr euch
eine Welt schreibt mir in die Kommentare
wie ihr das findet oder ob ich mehr so
steril vorgehen soll so diskret was
haltet Ihr davon oder mögt ihr mich wie
ich bin ich liebe euch auf jeden Fall
okay ich habe jetzt schon ca 2 Minuten
kein Fakt mehr gesag gesagt ihr spawt
halt hier und ihr könnt einfach J
drücken ach Quatsch nicht J ihr könnt l
drücken und dann seht ihr hier die Saga
ihr seht ich bin bei der Saga gerade so
weit das sind C 20% das ist noch nicht
so weit und eure erste Aufgabe wird sein
irgendwie finde drei cybermans also
diese hier drei cyberman und töte sie
und dann müsst ihr halt die töten ich
habe jetzt natürlich den Vorteil dass
ich schon Scouter habe etc deswegen kann
ich hier im Scouter mal ganz kurz F4 F4
drücken so da ist der Scouter an der
sucht jetzt bisschen dann kann ich
wieder F4 drücken dann sehe ich die
Distanz zum nächsten Mob alle hier in
der Nähe sind natürlich der zeigt mir
immer die nächsten an wenn ich jetzt
natürlich ein bisschen weiter weg Fliege
z.B zu diesem Dinosaurier da hinten so
jetzt ist er immer noch auf den
fokussiert wenn ich jetzt allerdings ein
bisschen weiter weggehe seht ihr geht
der gleich wieder runter und zwar jetzt
schon und dann seht ihr hier der
Dinosaurier das sind natürlich nicht 80
Blöcke sondern das sind so irgendwie
guck mal ich geh ein klein ganz kleines
Stück vorne das sind drei Sachen für
den ich weiß nicht ich glaube das sind
einfach diese Dings hier nee das kann ja
auch nicht sein dass das die Blöcke hier
sind doch ich glaube das S Pixel einfach
die man von dem Weg ist aber das kann
dann wieder auch nicht sein weil wenn
man anderes seack drin hat blablabla
allerdings sind es zeigt ja halt die
distance zu eine m deswegen der geht
jetzt runter und wenn ihr z.B durch eine
Höhle lauft dann ist es halt relativ gut
weil ihr dann seht wo der nächste Mob
ist dann kann man wieder F4 drücken
übrigens wenn ihr fliegt und F4 drückt
dann stoppt er immer kurz hier so dann
bleibt ihr stehen stehen stehen jetzt
bleibt der stehen ich habe nichts
gedrückt so jetzt bleibt i wieder stehen
Battle Power ist auch sehr interessant
und zwar könnt ihr sehen dass die
cybermans eine Battle Power von 12 1200
ca haben ist halt unterschiedlich so von
jedem zu jedem so ein bisschen
zum Vergleichen Creeper glaube ich 3000
oder 5000 ein Dinosaurier habe ich noch
gar nicht nachgeguckt ich glaube der hat
auf jeden Fall mehr 907 hat er nur warte
wie schnell kriegt ich i dann tot 3 4 5
6 7 8 9
10 na gut also wenn ihr dinosaur tötet
kriegt ihr dinosaur miet das ist halt
heftiger als das andere dinosaur das
andere dinosaur das andere miet was es
gibt das andere Fleisch dnom will
replanish 500 calories und 10% key also
ihr bekommt davon auch key wieder wenn
ihr das ist est key was ist Key Key ist
die Energie die ihr braucht um zu
fliegen um zu springen um bestimmte
Attacken zu machen ihr denkt jetzt
natürlich h luca du springst doch hier
ganz normal Blabla ja da wird key
natürlich nicht abgezogen ich lade das
mal kurz wieder auf sondern nur wenn ihr
J drückt ach nicht J wo ist den die
Taste wenn ihr x drückt springt der Halt
und hört mal auf die
Sounds das sind halt einfach mal genau
Dragon Ball Sounds und achtet mal auf
die key Engine oben links -2 -2 -2 ja
ihr könnt auch f gedrückt halten dann
fliegt ihr halt natürlich ich bin im
Creative aber wenn ihr natürlich die key
habt ihr seht das geht so langsam runter
so ca im sekundentag kriegt ihr mal
einen Key abgezogen wenn ich mal F3
drücke seht ihr hier dass die bei der Y
Achse dass ich hier immer weiter steige
ich kann es natürlich runter ich bekomme
natürlich keinen Fallschaden weil ich
die Rüstung an hab auch weil ich im
Creative bin aber ich habe auch die
Rüstung an ihr könnt auch f drücken und
dann irgendwann in der Luft Steuerung
einfach drücken und einfach von F auf
Steuerung Wechsel wenn ich Steuerung
jetzt loslasse F ich natürlich runter
aber wenn ihr F drückt und sagt so ah
die Höhe ist gut dann drückt einfach
Steuerung dann könnt ihr euch in der
Höhe weiter bewegen dann läuft die
keyleiste natürlich immer noch genauso
schnell runter allerdings bleibt ihr
halt auf dieser Höhe und steigt nicht
immer weiter und müsst dann steigen und
dann wieder ein bisschen runter und
wieder steigen so das ist halt besser
mit Steuerung kennt ihr wahrscheinlich
noch aus mega Projekt mit dem Jetpack
kann man konnte man das ja auch machen
dann wenn ihr jetzt seht oh nur noch 64
key könnt ihr einfach C gedrückt halten
und dann ladet ihr das mehr oder weniger
auf und es sind halt echt genau die
gleichen Sounds die es bei Dragon Ball
in der Serie gab und das ist das
todesgeil also das lädt sich jetzt hier
langsam so langsam auf und dann habe ich
jetzt wieder 110 ihr denkt jetzt
wahrscheinlich wenn ihr die Mod habt oh
ich habe doch hier nur bis Z und oh das
geht do so schnell leer und ich kann
nicht mal 10 Sekunden lang fliegen oder
kann ganz genau 10 Sekunden lang fliegen
aber ich kann hier nur fünf Sprünge
htereinander machen ist die K die key
Weg ja Leute deswegen scheiß dinosom
komm ich schenke euch das jetzt Jungs
hier
fresst deswegen könnt ihr J drücken und
ihr seht quasi eure Training Training
ihr seht eure Training points ihr seht
hier oben erstmal eure current DBC
experience das ist eure derzeitige
Dragon Ball Dragon Block C Erfahrung so
das ist 34 das ist wie viele Mops ihr
getötet habt ich habe 34 Mops getötet
das ist scheißegal wenn ich jetzt z.B
hier ein töte so die sind halt leicht zu
killen weil das ist einfach nur one hit
ihr seht schon die haben nur 1200
Energie und das ist einfach One Hit für
den dinosaur habe ich gerade V lang
gebraucht da passt die Battle Power
irgendwie nicht so ganz weil beim
dinosaur habe ich schon sechs sieben
Schläge gebraucht also hat der locker
irgendwie weiß nicht 7000 8000 9000 10
000 Battle Power jedenfalls habe ich
jetzt ja drei Leute oder so getötet
deswegen ist meine experience jetzt hier
bei 40 wenn ich jetzt hier noch einen
von denen töte ist meine experience auf
41 und wenn ich ein dinosaur töte ich
will jetzt nicht wieder zum nächsten
hinten hinfliegen der ist übrigens voll
brav
habe ich dann halt 42 warte ja habe ich
42 weil das steigt halt immer um ein und
nicht irgendwie das ein dinosaur viel
mehr bringt oder so weil es ist ja halt
die Erfahrung ist ja egal wenn man wenn
ihr z.B einen Dinosaurier tötet habt ihr
die gleiche Erfahrung gemacht dass ihr
ihn halt kennengelernt habt indem ihr
indem i halt getötet habt als wenn ihr
ein cyberman tötet das ist ja das
gleiche ich weiß nicht ob ich das gut
erklärt habe aber es ist ja die gleiche
Erfahrung es ist ja nicht so dass ihr
durch nur weil ein größeren tötet habt
ihr nicht gleich mehr Erfahrung das ist
ja genauso wie nur weil ihr mit dem Auto
eine Landstraße Fahrt heißt es ja nicht
habt ihr genau die gleiche Erfahrung
eigentlich dazu bekommen als wenn ihr
Autobahnfahrt weil es halt eine neue
Erfahrung für euch ist
Blabla Lua erklärmeister 3000 ja nein
wir kommen jetzt natürlich weiter und
zwar wenn ihr J drückt seht ihr hier die
Erfahrung die könnt ihr hier Training
points Butz jetzt sind hier fünf weniger
weil hier seht hier F Dragon Block C mal
P also das sind halt die Trading points
so F weniger 5 weniger f die kann man
jetzt halt umwandeln irgendwann sagt er
euch dann not enough experience to
convert also man hat nicht genug
experience die man in training points
verwandeln kann aus diesen Training
points denkt euch bestimmt was kann man
da machen ich Kön jetzt z.B mein Spirit
Aufladen auf 120 das heißt ihr seht oben
meine key beträgt jetzt 120 ich Kön noch
mal zwei Training points drauf packen so
dann seht ihr meine key beträgt 130 so
hier sind eure Training points und wenn
ich jetzt z.B auf fly noch einen drauf
packe so seht ihr hier das sinkt auf
vier und das hier steigt auf zwe also vi
und zi und das beansprucht zwei Training
points hier so jetzt habe ich nch zwei
Training points hier sind drei Training
points drauf und das ist auf drei das
heißt ich hab noch zwei kann ich
allerdings nicht machen weil man immer
einen braucht mindestens deswegen kann
ich noch ein auf Jump packen dann habe
ich halt nur noch ein und jetzt kann ich
halt hier gar nichts meh machen so habt
ihr es verstanden das gut ich rede jetzt
einfach mal so mit euch
also das meine ich so mit chilliger
Weise dass ich so dann Frage und blabla
gefällt euch das was das gut dann gibt
ein Daumen hoch nein Spaß ich bin nicht
ja Tutorial
scheiß cyberman Alter den schnotze
jetzt so wir machen bisschen weiter
Programm wo ist eigentlich mein Handy
ich denke mal so weißt du wenn ich hier
so rumschreie so mititten in der Nacht
dass du meine Eltern irgendwann so mein
nee hat keiner was geschrieben hat nur
ein snapchat bekommen oh so machen
mal weiter Programm so wo könn ich den
weitermen also wenn ihr die Story dann
halt mehr oder weiter mehr oder weniger
weiter spielt halt ich bin halt gerade
an dieser Stelle das Vegeta dass ich
jetzt zunamc reisen muss aber da will
ich jetzt noch nicht hin und bla bla da
muss jetzt jetzt ins Raumschiff steigen
hier ist das Raumschiff und da kann ich
damit rechts reinsteigen dann habe ich
hier eine Tastatur und kann dann
eingeben dass ich tunamc fliegen will
und blabla aber das will ich ja gar
nicht ihr könnt das mit Schift einfach
verlassen drauf schlagen dann bekommt
ihr es wieder damit Reisen übrigens auch
Leute wie Vegeta an etc oder warte was
Vegeta ja Vegeta jedenfalls
könnt ihr damit halt dann rumfliegen und
wie Taxi in GTA V mehr oder weniger und
das ist halt auch sehr geil weiter im
Programm Dragon
Balls sind überall in der Welt verteilt
wenn ich jetzt mir hier z.B mal so ein
Dings nehme so einen Dragon Ball Radar
so dann seht ihr hier ich sehe
nirgendswo Dragon Balls das ist halt
nämlich so die Sache ne die sind echt
schwer zu finden im ganz normalen
survival soll natürlich auch so sein
allerdings wenn man jetzt welche hat so
wie ich im Survival im Creative hier
kann man die zu einem h anordnen dann
einfach ein rechtsck drauf
machen Desire hier ist ein ganz normaler
Drache kennt ihr alle aus ronall wenn
ihr es geguckt habt könnt ihr rechts
drauf machen natürlich auch wenn ihr es
geguckt hab macht ihr auch immer rechts
wenn ihr geguckt habt nein Spaß
m können z.B Diamond anklicken da kriegt
i drei
Diamanten
gr ne dann Ken wir jetzt hier z.B wieder
machen wenn ich jetzt z.B wie gesagt bla
blaa Quatsch mal nicht so viel kching
Shad so jetzt habe ich jetzt z
ja ich liebe dich du darfst jetzt wieder
gehen ich habe dich e ganz weg da Krieg
z. kin man braucht echt eine Menge eine
Menge von den Dragon BS um
drei Dings zu machen drei Drachen zu
machen damit man drei bekommt es gibt
auch noch namc Dragon Balls die findet
ihr halt auf namc die könnt ihr halt
auch so anordnen habt ihr
das
wow so das ist ist bisschen größer der
ist echtes todesgroß ist mega heftig
groß Alter echt so krass der ist so
heftig groß ne zieht euch das mal rein
also der diea auch nacher Zeit deswegen
ich klick erst mal drauf Moment ich
klick mal hier unten drauf so da kann
ich jetzt z.B sagen King Schatz und
dann ja danke tschüss piss dich der hat
auch ein viel cooleren Abgang als dieser
komische andere Dragon na ja jedenfalls
ist dann hier kaching Shard habe ich
dann halt jetzt vier weil ich vorhin
schon ein hatte das sind halt drei dazu
gekommen das ist halt auch sehr geil
wenn man halt diese größeren Dragon BS
findet übrigens Dragon BS die einfach so
platziert werden auf dem
Dragon da da zwar so ganz normal
angezeigt wie ein Dragon Ball aber sind
halt versteinerte Dragon Balls im Dings
im Survival dann deswegen bringt das
nicht viel sensobohne wie schon gesagt
könnt ihr Essen und es füllt halt
[Musik]
komplette sens stamina
stamina Ernährungs hungerleiste hungerle
das Wort habe ich gesucht und halt auch
eure KI auf deswegen also eure key
deswegen wenn ihr das Phas ist halt
schon mega chillig sieht halt noch ein
bisschen komisch aus hört sich aber
genauso an
so also meine key wenn ihr mal guckt ist
gerade von 129 auf 130 gestiegen gibt's
halt hier noch verschiedene andere
Scouter die ihr Hal euch halt auch
aufsetzen können hier z.B jetzt der
gelbe was der Unterschied ist ich weiß
es nicht genau könntet ihr mir ja
eventuell mal in die Kommentare
schreiben habe ich jetzt nicht
rausgefunden ich glaube das ist gar kein
großer Unterschied halt nur wie das halt
zur Rüstung jetzt mehr oder weniger
passt weil ein paar andere Charaktere in
Dragon Ball hat natürlich auch
verschiedene Scouter diese Blöcke hier
warte habe ich noch irgendwas was ich
euch so zeigen möchte also die Rüstung
hier an sich die ist warte ich kann es
euch mal ganz kurz hier so zeigen
survival ich bin halt wah ich bin halt
komplett voll die können mich schlagen
wie Sie wollen ich verliere fast keine
leben weil ich halt diese heftige
Rüstung habe ja Jungs Alter die gehen
direkt alle auf mich los Alter ich habe
euch alle gespawnt i Penner seid mal
dankbar alter Junge jetzt geht's ab hier
jetzt geht's ab jetzt ist Massaker nein
ich geh mal wieder in creative weil ich
kein Bock habe dass mir hinterherlufen
was es halt auch noch gibt ist St diese
Teile hier das sind diese spawnteile
mehr oder weniger im Creative könnt ihr
wer einfach setz und ganz viel rechts
drauf machen dann könnt ihr da ganz
viele Leute von denen spawen deswegen
habe ich das gerade gemacht damit ich
euch das ein bisschen zeigen kann wenn
man die puncht und schlägt und kaputt
macht und so die stehen ja halt auch
überall rum wo sind ein paar den hier
habe ich z.B nicht gesetzt allerdings im
Creative kann man jetzt einfach rechts
drauf machen im Survival Spawn die da
dann halt mal ab und zu es ist so wie
ein Spawner nur mit einer viel
geringeren und viel exponentiell nicht
so steigenden Rate an Mobs und an
Schwierigkeit das ist halt genau das
gleiche halt mal 5 Minuten Delay mal 3
Minuten Delay das ist halt komplett
anders da spaw die halt so mehr oder
weniger drin was haben wir hier denn
sonst noch was ich euch sagen kann ja
diese Kristalle sind halt für alles
mögliche da die braucht ihr halt überall
für irgendwie auch für Rüstung etc sind
halt auch na ja also so schwer sind
jetzt nicht zu bekommen also es geht die
kleben z.B hier mal dran hier sind ein
paar warces warte wie viele sind
hier ja a Stück z.B hab ihr a Stück
waren a waren a waren a
und das ist halt Boch man jetzt blickt
das hier wieder alles es ist halt
eigentlich ganz leicht zu kriegen bzw
geht so sonst habe ich eigentlich gar
nicht mehr so viele Sachen die ich euch
zeigen muss möchte Blabla ich kann euch
jetzt hier noch zeigen ja wow Nimbus
cool habe ich hier Nimbus kann ich drauf
klicken dann kann ich damit so ein
bisschen rum rumschweben hier hey
hui macht voll Spaß hier und so aber
sieht auf jeden Fall witzig
aus ein paar Screenshots gemacht so nein
flieg zurück du blöder Pisser so mit
Schiff kann ich da runter dann kann ich
den einfach kaputt schlagen dann habe
ich wieder mein Nimbus dann kann ich
wieder rumfliegen unnötig weil man das
eigentlich auch mit Key machen kann und
so kann ich mich halt dann wieder mit
Key
aufladen dann kann ich auch mit F
fliegen aber Nimbus geht halt noch ein
bisschen schneller am schnellsten geht
glaube ich das hier und ich find es auch
eigentlich am coolsten durch so ein
kleines Fenster hier durch und es geht
halt am schnellsten sieht man halt auch
schon so ich geh mal wieder auf meine
Plattform hier
oben so komm zack ah moment du kommst
sch wieder mit mehr
so sonst haben wir eigentlich gar nicht
mehr viel was ich euch zeigen muss es
gibt ja natürlich noch so ein paar
Blöcke zeige ich euch gleich noch ganz
am Ende hier sonst auch witzig zu wissen
dass dieses Ding hier z.B auch voll die
hohe voll den hohen angriffschaden hat
also es hat halt fünf angriffschaden
aber man kann damit halt trotzdem
teilweise Schweine oder so mit zwei
Schlägen töten einfach nur mit dem Griff
das ist so selbsttironisch na ja egal
sonst muss ich gar nicht mehr viel hier
zu sagen hier sind so ein paar von
diesen Blöcken die ihr gerade gesehen
habt die hier drin waren wie z.B das den
silvercor Stone und sowas alles jetzt
sind z. z. hier so ein paar Sachen hier
das ist der grey color Stone das ist
hierf gemacht dieses himmelsschloss hier
ich einfach hier durch hier ist korin
hieß der so der kleine haseekatze keine
Ahnung was ist ask for sensubin so jetzt
habe ich eine sensohne bekommen achtet
mal auf meine
key willst nicht fressen jetzt ne doch
jetzt hat er
gefräen
so so der sagt jetzt bla bla bla blaa
komm am nächsten Morgen wieder dann habe
ich wieder was für dich also hierfür
sind halt so die Blöcke so Blabla das
ist halt se ein komischer Luftballon
Tempel bla dann können wir hier mal
dieses diesen Dings sch hochfliegen die
große Gebilde
und tada schreibt mir in Kommentare ob
ihr noch wisst wie dieser Tempel hier
heißt na na schreibt mal es ist
tempempel hier haben wir Kami Kami war
der der euch die ganzen der euch die
ganzen Sachen beibringt der gibt euch
z.B Nimbus womit ihr rumfliegen könnt ja
geil und der bringt euch auch die KI
Attacken bei die Kia Attacken und da
könnt ihr auch dann abilities und Saga
System also eure Story nachgucken und
sowas alles ich gehe mal noch hier so
ein bisschen
in in spirit ach kann ich gar nicht ich
muss er mal hier in training points so
ein Spirit investiere ich ein bisschen
und ja mehr kann ich auch gar nicht
damit ich jetzt einfach mal auf
140 Spirit
bin geny war geny dama oder war gamy
Gang oder ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau
wie es heißt es ist halt echt schon 7
Jahre her dass ich Dragon Ball Z mal
irgendwie wieder geguckt habe muss ich
mal wieder nachholen das ist allerdings
wenn man C gedrückt hat und G drückt
dann kann man halt für eine Zeit
schneller laufen und man kann sich halt
auch verwandeln in saagin dass man halt
dann auch auf Dauer viel schneller läuft
etc etc etc könnt ihr alles selbst
ausprobieren ihr müsst dafür allerdings
die Story durchh haben und sowas alles
und wie ihr gesehen habt ich bin jetzt
bei 20%. jetzt natürlich auf die Sachen
auf die ihr alle gewartet
habt ihr könnt den die mittlere
Maustaste Eindrücken wie gesagt ihr
müsst in der Story voran sein ihr könnt
jetzt nicht einfach world machen wo ihr
in irgendeinem Biom seid und ich könnt
euch natürlich so ein paar Sachen
cheaten wie z.B Rüstung und so
allerdings so ein paar Sachen wie key
Attacken und so müsst ihr halt im
survivalwelt machen dass ihr in diesem
Biom seid dass dieser Typ das Kami spawt
etc und dass ihr halt auf jeden Fall ein
bisschen Energie habt also key so ich
habe jetzt z.B big bangy TEAG die kostet
66 K dafür gehe ich mal ein bisschen
runter hier in mein mein building hier
rein wo die paar Leute hier sind und
jetzt kann ich einfach Rechte maaste
drücken wenn ich das hier halt da rechts
ausgedrückt habe ihr seht schon wenn ich
hochgucke Blabla
so
ich muss das gedrückt halten sorry
Jungs wer hat die größten Eier in der
Hut ja so jetzt kann ich mich hier
wieder aufladen so ein
bisschen so und jetzt die anderen
Attacken könnt ihr euch ja selbst
angucken ich kann jetzt wieder mittlere
Maustaste drücken das kostet z.B nur 15
aber ihr müsst halt auch genau treffen
damit halt ein bisschen Schaden macht
macht halt damage 10 Herzen also ich
glaube ich muss zweimal da drauf
schießen damit einer
stirbt was komm
jetzt ach nee muss noch ein bisschen
öfter drauf schießen na ist jetzt auch
egal der kostet auf jeden Fall 15 key
dann haben wir burning attack 72 ke mach
63 Herz Blabla ihr seht halt alles das
explode z.B ground da kann ich jetzt z.B
so
machen ne was ich euch aber zeigen
möchte ist L mir mal nebenbei bisschen
auf kamh auf jeden Fall hört euch
einfach mal diese diese tonspor an von
kamh
[Musik]
also das ist echt so episch es sind
einfach genau die gleichen Sounds wie in
der Serie in den Spielen das ist so geil
kam times 10 sagt er gleich glaube
ich Moment
[Musik]
times 10 und das ist halt hat ein damage
von 48 hat irgendwas ein höheren damage
ich weiß es gerade gar nicht was ist das
überhaupt
warte was haben hat irgendwas ein
höheren damage da Supernova Alter das
habe ich total vergessen dafür brauchen
man aber 215 key und dafür muss ich noch
so viel Leute töten und in der Story
noch weiterkmen bzw halt eine Menge
Leute töten einfach mein mein Spirit ein
bisschen höher setzen ich weiß nicht wie
hoch kann ich jetzt mein Spirit setzen
auf 150 halt sonst brauche ich jetzt
drei Training points das heißt ich
brauch eine Menge Training points noch
mehr und wir sind bei einer halben
Stunde Mod Review angelangt na ja
jedenfalls ich würde sagen ich beende
das ganz jetzt erstmal den Rest also die
Planeten namc und die ganzen anderen
Sachen die Story weiter und die Saga die
Freezer Saga kommt auch noch ein Freezer
tritt in allen Formen auf und blablabla
den meisten wird das wahrscheinlich
gerade eh nichts sagen weil obwohl die
meisten haben gucken glaube ich sogar
gerade noch Po Dragon Ball die sind so
gerade in alter wo ich das so geguckt
habe so vor also die meisten hier sind
ja glaube ich 13 oder so ich habe das ja
ich bin jetzt fast 18 ja es ist so 5 se
Jahre her bei mir m ihr werdet das
wahrscheinlich verstehen dass es einfach
die geilste Serie war die es hier gab
nemen Pokémon und Yu-Gi-Oh und ich bin
finde die Mod auf jeden Fall sehr geil
was ich ein bisschen schwammig finde ist
noch dass z.B Schwerter so mega viel
ziehen alter das ist ein bisschen crazy
aber die Gegner werden auch nachher
richtig heftig und vor allem in der
zweiten Mission kommt glaube ich Vegeta
ich weiß nicht ob ich mich gerade
täusche was Vegeta ich verhandel hier
schon die ganze Zeit paar komische Namen
al ich verwechsel schon die ganze Zeit
paar Namen weil es halt echt lange her
ist und der hat halt glaube ich ein der
hat eine Battle Power von 10.000 das ist
so heftig weil ein Creeper z.B hat
glaube ich 3000 und
der attackiert halt zurück und lädt auch
noch nebenbei dann wieder auf und sowas
alles und das macht Creeper natürlich
nicht ein Zombie kann ich sagen oh du
hast mich einmal geboxt ich lade mal
eben wieder auf kann ich natürlich nicht
sagen also dann auch ein bisschen dass
die Schwerter sind dafür natürlich
ausgelegt und ist gut dafür allerdings
müssen dann noch diamantschwerter und
sowas alles halt höher sein allerdings
müssten die auch wieder schwieriger zu
machen sein weil einfach mit dem
komischen Griff der zwei Leder und ein
Eisen braucht hat man schon plus F
angriffschaden was normalerweise ein
Eisenschwert hat ist ein bisschen
komisch geplant ist allerdings an sich
richtig geil gemacht vor allem mit der
Story spielt auf jeden Fall mal die
Story auf wenn ihr kein Dragon Ball
kennt ihr wirdet euch wird halt immer
gesagt ja Reise da und dahin oder töte
den und den und das ist auf jeden Fall
hammergeil und die Mod ist auf jeden
Fall so hammer schaffen wir 10.000 likes
ich weiß es ist heftig und ich habe noch
nie so viel likes irgendwie gefragt ob
ihr das schafft aber schaffen mir
wirklich 10 000 Likes auf diese Mod
Review weil ich habe mich echt jetzt den
kompletten Tag darauf vorbereitet mir
die ganzen Sachen beigebracht hier damit
ich euch das so zeigen kann
und schaffen wir halt 10.000 likes für
diese Mod Review das wird echt
hammergeil das wäre echt super mega
krass amazing schreibt mal wenn ihr
jetzt übrigens gerade überhaupt noch
dran seid und 30 Minuten euch das alles
angeg hab schreibt mal bitte alle in die
Kommentare Dragon Ball oder schreibt mir
allgemein eure Serie die ihr so richtig
gern damals gesuchtet habt und jetzt
mache ich hier noch einmal ein khh
Moment was mache ich ja komm mal hier
eben ja das war natürlich nicht so
euphorisch und episch weil ich war halt
in Dings ich war in der oberen Welt hier
und ich reise jetzt noch mal in eine
andere Welt bind gespoilert hier kann
man übrigens nicht sprinten etc wo bin
ich hier schreibt in die Kommentare ich
würde sagen wir sehen uns beim nächsten
Mal wieder könnt mir weiter Mod Reviews
Mods schreiben die ich reviewen soll
auch wenn ihr solche großen Mod Reviews
wollt oder wollt ihr eher so kleine Mod
Reviews von demem scheiß Mod oder so
deswegen schreibt mir das einfach und
dann würde ich sagen nehen wir uns in
der nächsten Folge wieder Steig jetzt
eben auf den Dings und dann
[Musik]
tschüss